when an athlete performs
there is just the flow
there is no identity
separation
time or ideas
the same thing is true during dance
art creation or combat
one is in the zone
feeling everything
cherishing the is-ness
any ideas of being an entity in time are
impossible to be present
if they arise the flow is immediately
lost to to self-consciousness
how am I performing
how am I being perceived
am I good enough
it is a contraction of the whole into an
illusion of being a separate part
when there is no entity there is Pure
Flow
these questions never arise
there is a fearlessness and conviction
that cannot be found elsewhere
this is why spiritual realization of
empty light yields purity of flow
The Entity Mirage is no longer able to
be formed
ever
this purity of flow is an absolute trip
on every sensation emotion
thought
relationship transformation contraction
and expansion
loving the dance is like being a tree or
a bird chirping on the branch
it is like being a Sensei hysterically
laughing then sniping delusion
it is a complete and utter surrender
into the mysterious infinite flow
allowing everything to be as it is like
the sunlight shines
learning how to dive deeper into love
learning how to balance it with wisdom
it is the visceral and irreversible
realization
that nothing is happening outside of
perception
perception is obviously the ultimate
experiencing creation
there is nothing left
but to die into the dance
to completely and utterly die on your
sword
with all with multiple reality
is As It Seems
the ancient ceremonies I set your mind
and body free
is what this would be
okay an opportunity to embrace all your
different subjects
dilate your third eye
the tribal wisdoms